ps regardez donc on va se parler
aujourd'hui on se parle de ce smartphone
c'est le pourquoi x3 procès le
smartphone fait pour les gamers
il a l'air plutôt cool sur le principe
il n'est pas extrêmement cher on va tout
de suite commencer par là vous êtes tous
noté là dessus en fait vous avez deux
configurations
si j'ai bien de ram 128 go de stockage
ou 8 gigas de ram 256 go de stockage je
vais tout vous expliquer dans quelques
instants la version 628 elle coûte 249
euros 90 et la version 8 256 coûte 299
euros 90 donc on à 250 euros ou 300
euros
[Musique]
donc un petit elle l'a aurélien aurélie
[Applaudissements]
welcome to the book of family thank you
for sharing poko ici qu'est ce qu'on a
ces petits autocollants ouais c'est
marrant ça guide de démarrage je vois
que j'ai double nano sim ou nano symplus
carte microsd ça c'est la carte de
garantie j'ai une petite coque avec ce
que j'aime bien déjà effectivement c'est
que là vous avez ce que tu es maths
peuvent vous a rencontré il ya vraiment
une différence de toucher là ça glisse
voilà tout ce talent bien plus rugueux
c'est un plastique dans tous les côtés
traces de doigt ici par contre on va les
avoir ici on les a pas chez les 4
capteurs dans mon capteur principal qui
est là le branding poko qui est assez
sympa prise jack
dans ce segment de prix c'est normal de
la recharge en usb c'est le micro le
haut parleur la deuxième haut-parleurs
qui va situé ici au niveau de la grille
la petite caméra qui perd ses micros
pour la réduction brouille est toujours
dans l'infrarouge aussi tiroirs de
cartes s'initie capteur d'empreintes
digitales pour déverrouiller est ici et
mon bouton volume
ok il ya l'intérieur qu'est ce que j'ai
encore bloc de charge là mon câble là et
puis comme on est en france genre des
écouteurs t'es pas dans la voie de
presse mais normalement vous aurez vous
des écouteurs que ça c'est une
obligation en france moi y'a un truc
tout de suite qui m'interpelle c'est
poisse un smartphone qui fait 2 115
grammes c'est pas de plus léger à voir
si pour vous le fait d'avoir un
smartphone à plus de 200 grammes à 215 g
ça peut être problématique ou non et
puis le deuxième chose c'est la
dimension aujourd'hui ça ne les
smartphones avec les écrans vingt
neuvième 21/9 ils se réduisent un petit
pour l'argent et celui là on l'argent
que j'ai du mal à faire toucher mon
pouce et mon majeur alors j'y arrive en
mai c'est un peu en guerre
alors vous avez plutôt d'autres
smartphones aujourd'hui voyez où on y
arrive beaucoup plus facilement donc
c'est vraiment on pourrait se dire un
point de détail mais malgré tout ça
compte six ans cap que l'écran lui-même
vous avez un grand écran de 6,67 poussée
du full hd plus ici la résolution de
1400 par 1080 à 395 1 pixels par pouce
et un ratio vingt neuvième
on nous annonce aussi une luminosité
maximale de 450 litres c'est pas la main
avant la plus grosse luminosité donc si
vous voulez jouer en plein soleil il ya
un moment où ça risque de coincer bon
d'être cotées 250 300 euros voilà on
remet tout ça un peu en perspective le
gros point positif ici c'est que vous
avez un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz tout en sachant qu'ici vous avez
ce qu'on appellera dainik switch c'est
un switch intelligente entre 50 60 90 ou
120 hertz en fonction des besoins de
l'application
l'idée c'est de consommer moins de
batterie un smartphone moins énergivore
tôt sachant que pour le gaming vous avez
un taux d'échantillonnage tactile de 240
à hertz donc une latence réduite
alors moi il ya un truc que je suis un
peu moyen moyen c'est sur le schéma de
couleurs par défaut
il est comme ça et là je trouve qu'il
fait un peu mal aux yeux je trouve
agressif
on est sur un espèce de bleu blanc qui
vient vraiment vous taper dans l'oeil
alors vous avez plusieurs possibilités
soit vous restez en automatique comme ça
par défaut ça fait un petit peu mal
saturé ça viendra ajouter comme son nom
l'indiqué un peu plus de saturation ou
standard ça vient le jaune hier c'est ce
que je vais préférer comme ça tout de
suite mais ce que je vais faire en
réalité moi je vais bien bidouiller un
peu nommé en automatique et dans ma
température de couleur je viens en
personnalisés et là je viens monter
légèrement
je viens le cas c'est au niveau des
jeunes orange ce qui vient m'apporte
quelque chose de plus confortable à
l'oeil et je trouve ça beaucoup mieux et
beaucoup plus reposant et beaucoup moins
agressif qu'on parle de gaming bien
évidemment mais ya pas que le gaming et
aussi bien évidemment des expériences en
visionnage de série de films compagnie
et netflix my canal 10 n'est plus et
tout ça ici vous avez en white van
eslande permettra de regarder votre
contenu sur my canal 10 n'a pu cette
compagnie en full hd donc ça c'est bien
on nous dit par contre vous avez des
hauts parleurs stéréo alors haut
parleurs stéréo
je veux bien mais on s'en doutera on a
un léger déséquilibre ce qu'on se rend
compte tout de suite ici là c'est que
votre par leurs récits sur la drague à
l'eau par la principale qui aura le
meilleur spectre est le meilleur son et
celui là sur la gauche sera un peu en
soulevant une fois de plus ça ça me
paraît normal sur un smartphone à 250
300 euros rien d'étonnant là dessus ça
vient rajouter un petit pan d'immersion
le fait d'avoir trop parleurs de côté là
mais il ya un certain déséquilibre et
s'est pas complètement dingue si on
vient chercher un peu plus de musique
voyez là il à fond quand il est à fond
il vous reste que des médiums si vous
voulez récupérer des basses condé c'est
un petit peu le son voyez là on récupère
un peu de son g sur le côté c'est pas à
complètement dingos une fois de plus de
150 300 euros je le répète beaucoup mais
c'est là vraiment la réaction il faut
vraiment leur situer par rapport à son
positionnement tarifaire mais si vous
voulez aller beaucoup plus loin pour
l'expérience audio et pour le gaming et
bien il vous faudra mettre ici un petit
casque branché qu'une petite prise jack
ou sinon vous allez du bluetooth 5.0
puisqu'on parle de gaming ici on va
venir parler de performance ici vous
êtes un qualcomm snapdragon 860 on est
dans la série 8 la série 8 c'est le haut
de gamme chez qualcomm ce que vous
permettra de faire ce processeur et bien
c'est tout simplement d'avoir des
expériences de jeu maximisez vous allez
faire tourner beaucoup de jeu même les
jeux les plus gourmands dont ça s'est
super bien ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que ce processeur ne gère pas la 5g
moussa donc sûr de la 4g
donc si vous voulez acheter un
smartphone bourges mac de la 5g dans la
rue haut débit et bien si ça sera pas le
carbon ça s'est une fois de plus du
point de détail déjà enquête j'ai vous
pouvez jouer devrait donc soit 6 soit 8
gigas de ram c'est de la pdr 4x standard
dans cette gamme de prix par contre ils
ont fait un effort et ça ça c'est
intéressant au niveau du stockage et
vous ont mis un grand minimum de 128 il
vous monter jusqu'à 256 extensible dans
les deux cas jusqu'à 1 tera grâce à une
carte microsd mais surtout ce qui est
intéressant c'est la technologie drame
derrière c'est lui ai fait trois points
1 alors que dans cette gamme de prix
on s'attendrait surtout avoir de lui ai
fait ce 2.0 au-delà de ces chiffres un
peu barbare ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est qu'avec l'usb 3.0 et bien vous
allez avoir une vitesse de lecture et
d'écriture qui va être optimisée qui
permettra d'aller plus loin et donc
d'avoir un accès à l'information
beaucoup plus rapide alors y'a un truc
qui nous ont mis pour le gaming c'est un
moteur linéaire sur l'axé z explique en
fait vous avez une espèce de petit de
petites comment dire un petit mot un
petit truc qui vient taper sur votre
smartphone en rythme à l'intérieur par
rapport au jeu donc si vous jouez à un
jeu de tir dès que ça shoote eh bien
vous le sentirez sous votre doigt sa
passion que c'est plus 60 moi
personnellement je suis pas très fan de
ça parce que je suis un garçon qui
tremble le des mains et venir me
rajouter une sensation de vibrations
plus c'est pas mon kiff
il ya des gens qui aimeront donc ça ça
dépend vraiment de tout un chacun en
tout cas c'est là et ça peut être
intéressant même lorsque vous regardez
un film vous avez de la musique et bien
vous le sentez vous avez également
logis de refroidissement c'est la liquid
cool 1.0 plus qui permettrait à devenir
refroidir votre smartphone sur des
périodes de gaming alors si vous jouez
on le sent quand même je sens au dos que
ça chauffe un petit peu vous allez
gagner 6 degrés à peu près et point
intéressant c'est que vous avez une
grosse batterie de 5160 milliampères
heures avec un chargeur de 33 watts
inclus et vous avez une technologie
technologique est propre à xiaomi
justement et poko ca technologies mmt à
lorsque vous permet de faire cette
technologie est même temps je vais voulu
illustrer sur un bout de papier
qu'est ce qui se passe lorsqu'un
smartphone via se recharge et bien vous
avez tout votre batterie l'énergie va
rentrer par là il va commencer à le
recharger à leur charge et à leurs
charges et donc plus vous êtes au début
et plus ça va vite et vous voyez quand
vous arrivez à la fin elle et 10%
dernier sa main tant dingue et sa
recharge vraiment assez lentement la
technologie mmt en fait au lieu
d'attaquer par le bout comme ça et
d'avancer progressivement et bien en
fait elle vient au centre et elle vient
de répartir uniformément à gauche et à
droite de votre batterie
savard charger plus rapidement et vous
allez éviter d'avoir ce petit problème
de charge des derniers pourcentages qui
vont ramer puisque vous venez de
distribuer d'un côté et de l'autre voilà
c'est un petit accès une petite astuce
ça fonctionne c'est une techno elle est
plutôt intéressant ici bien évidemment
retourner sur me wade douce et
l'expérience de chiots micoud retrouve
sur poko vous avez votre tiroir
d'applications plein de petits réglages
bongo à 12 on est déjà parlé moi j'aime
bien tout est classé par à thématique
communication divertissements photos et
compagnie bons il ya plein de petites
astuces j'ai fait une vidéo sur me wade
invite à venir la découvrir
moi j'aime bien l'expérience et je la
trouve vraiment très très sympa après il
ya toute la partie photo ap à ce que la
photo c'est un usage aujourd'hui qui est
vraiment important sur sur smartphone en
fait vous avez un premier capteur de 40
8 mégapixels tube right 1.79 akka
technologies cap pixels en main pour
capter plus de lumière et pour la photo
notamment faible luminosité on va
regarder les résultats dans quelques
instants
vous avez ensuite un ultra grand-angle
de 8 mégapixels avec un champ de vision
219 degrés qui ouvre à f 2.2 en bas vous
avez de capteur de 2 mégapixels tour f
2.4 le premier c'est de la macro de
croire qu'il me chacune d'histoire de 4
cm elle deuxième 114 profondeur pour le
fameux effet bloqués tandis qu'à l'avant
les votre caméra de sel feeds mégapixels
touvre f 2.2 alors ici l'idée ce qu'on
peut dire a filmé jusqu en 4k à 30
images par seconde
vous avez plein de petites options
notamment au niveau de la vidéo vous
avez ce qu'ils vont appliquer ce que
tout le monde fait un peu en ce moment
c'est le duel vie
oh ça vous partage l'écran en fait vous
avez d'un côté ce qu'il va y avoir
derrière l'autre côté ce qui est devant
brasser du picture in picture vous
changez vous pouvez le passé on petit
pouvais le passer au rang 1 regarder les
photos alors laissant capteur principal
franchement c'est pas mal c'est vraiment
pas mal ça tire un poil sur jeunes sur
les façades on a bien le détail au
niveau du ciel on voit bien les branches
non c'est très cohérent
je passe ensuite sur l'ultra grand
talent on perd vraiment en précision et
vous le verrez tout au long mais c'est
normal une fois de plus à ce prix là on
peut venir zone est un peu dans l'image
parce qu'on parle du 48 mégapixels on va
venir en fait runje dans l'image
on arrive à avoir indiqué pas trop mal
mais si vous allez trop loin vous ou
métro fois cent fois décevoir et bien
c'est pas beau c'est pas terrible et
c'est normal la caméra de celle fille
est pas mauvaise elle fait le taf au
niveau de la peau sococé pas c'est pas
exceptionnel capteur principal on
continue ici regardez la gestion du ciel
est quand même plutôt bien faut que
voilà en extérieur d'une façon un peu
globale ça marche bien l'ultra grand
angle on perd en précision et c'est
normal on vient se rapprocher un peu
d'accord et dès que c'est trop c'est un
beau et c'est un peu la même chose
qu'ils aient retrouvé sur toutes les
photos on le voit davantage notamment
dans moins de lumière alors on le voit
il ya plus de bruit c'est beaucoup moins
précis ça va pas non plus être magique
monde et sur un smartphone à 250 euros
300 euros et dès qu'on passe un ultra
grand angle voyage de son la lumière
tout est cramé s'ébruiter c'est pas beau
rien de surprenant on peut zoomer un peu
on se rapproche on a beaucoup de bruit
sur le côté il a un petit peu de mal là
effectivement avec cette scène là qui
est un peu plus complexe pour lui la
nuit c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
pas terrible c'est très poussif 1 on le
voit les goûts changent vraiment à tout
compenser on à la différence que ce que
vous voyez dans la petite fenêtre là est
ce que vous voyez à l'extérieur c'est
très poussif
c'est pas très beau bon c'est pas non
plus là dessus qu'on s'attend à voir des
merveilles au niveau de la photo de nuit
sur l'ultra grand angle on oublie
complètement et on peut se rapprocher
mais vraiment c'est pas là c'est pas
beau et une fois de plus un jeu pas vous
le recommander la macro alors la macro
c'est toujours difficile à trouver la
bonne distance s'ébruiter le rendu n'est
vraiment pas exceptionnel quand vous
arrivez à peu près à trouver votre
distance c'est ce qui n'est pas toujours
très évident et bien vous le voyez la
lgo vient tout compenser il nous brut la
scène
c'est très peu naturel et au final on
n'a pas de la macro on a quelque chose
qui donne un effet un peu plastique aux
plantes et moi personnellement j'aime
pas et ensuite et bien le mode avec la
loi de portraits avec les facebook et là
j'ai un petit problème d'exposer vos
duos des cheveux c'est un peu plus
cramer sinon c'est somme toute assez
cohérent sans être exceptionnel sa smart
phones cas également du nfc notamment
pour google paye donc ça c'est plutôt
pas mal aussi du wifi 5 et il est
certifié ip 53 résistant aux
éclaboussures donc s'il se met à
pleuvoir un petit peu vous éclabousser
sa vague moi je les aime bien ce
smartphone je trouve pas mal maintenant
le petit truc je vous le dis une fois de
plus c'est le poids est ce que jouer
comme ça qu'un smartphone à 215 grammes
dans votre main est ce que ça va vous
tentez oui ou non l'expérience logiciel
est super intéressante et ça c'est
vraiment un gros point positif est là
dessus puis le tarif
il est quand même vraiment bien placé
250 300 tout en sachant qu'on en période
de pré commandes on parle de lancement
il ya des remises
donc ça vaut le coup de jeter un oeil
l'idée de la marque asus est vraiment
devenir draguer les gamer avec des
bouillouses entourent 250 300 euros donc
si vous êtes gamer et que vous avez ce
budget là bien vous pouvez y aller pour
moi son problème la recharge est bonne
elle est rapide
le processeur tient vraiment la route
expérience logiciel est cool la photo
est en dessous mais bon c'est normal et
on s'y attendre à vous et votre capteur
principal de 48 mégapixels qui marche
bien mais c'est souvent un peu l'idée
dans ce gamme de prix là donc pour moi
voilà c'est une bonne solution sur un
bon smartphone et s'il vous tente une
fois de plus de 1000 le lien en bas par
la description vous me dire ce que vous
en pensez en barque au contact on se
retrouve très vite m'ont beaucoup
d'amour des gros coeur et puis pour les
soins de vous tous